we're gonna go to uh kathy wood next
kathy did
a uh an excellent job she uh used what i
would consider a judo move to talk about
uh
this topic and she knew that esg was
gonna be a a topic of discussion
and so she reminded everyone esg stands
for environmental social and governance
right
and if you think about it she
essentially broke down these three
components to talk about bitcoin she
said
from an environmental perspective uh
these quotes are coming from a fortune
article
bitcoin will be much more
environmentally friendly certainly than
traditional gold mining or the
traditional financial services sector
in many ways it already is so she's
basically saying wait i'm checking the
box
as to why i believe bitcoin meets the
environmental goals
uh and efforts of the esg narrative she
then went to social and said the
s social providing financially
underserved people with access to
payment technology
everywhere around the world without
friction is one of the most societal
uh positive impacts you can make give
everyone access
to financial services without friction
around the world again
checking the box of s and esg and then
lastly governance saying
offering transparency unlike the
opicnics of financial systems and the
toll takers in the traditional financial
world
so checking the box on the g and she
explicitly said
she is drawn to bitcoin because of esg
whereas most people say oh we have esg
concerns around bitcoin
kathy wood one of the best money
managers on wall street
who's absolutely taking the financial uh
kind of industry by storm with these
actively managed etfs
clearly articulating bitcoin is the esg
asset and breaking down point by point
how she sees that happening
now i'm super biased and most people
have heard my views on this
i completely agree with her here what do
you two think in terms of
uh kind of using bitcoin as uh an asset
to fit into this esg narrative
i think uh i think it was smart i think
that she kind of went
against kind of what everyone else has
said on the subject but i think it was
smart to frame it in the esg
kind of mindset because it's become sort
of a buzzword in on wall street and kind
of investment strategies across the
world
and while we were talking i was looking
up some kind of interesting stats around
esg
and there's a blackrock report from last
year that said they basically surveyed
kind of all their investors and
different clients across their their
business units
and they said that investors
representing 25 trillion in assets
plan to double esg assets in the next
five years
and if you look at it from kind of where
we where we used to be and where we are
now
uh bloomberg did a similar report and
esg assets in
2016 represented 22.8 trillion uh by the
end of this year it's supposed to be
about 54 trillion
so explosive growth almost doubling
basically in five years
can i can i just say uh what it is um
i think the entire esg narrative is
mostly virtue signaling 100 that's what
i meant by buzzword really was just kind
of like
we're allocating some capital to this
space we care about it right like
but here's the thing is most people
aren't uh let's see if the best business
show research team can quickly get on
the google machine
and do some work there's a study that
showed a bunch of funds
uh drastically increased their usage of
the words esg
uh you know environmental social
governance and esg
but didn't actually change the
investment mix of the funds
so they would say things like oh we're
starting to take into account esg
or we are going to explicitly look for
esg investments but then they didn't
change
any of their actual investments and so
it was complete virtue signaling
and on top of that if you bring it to
bitcoin specifically i've had two
separate people come on the podcast now
if you take let's say like the marathon
ceo one of the larger north american
mining businesses
what they originally said at one point
was hey we are going to explicitly
try to optimize for esg
friendly bitcoin meaning that it had to
be mined
with certain energy mix and what
happened was the reason why they went
after that was there was an economic
incentive they believed that investors
would pay a
premium for esg friendly bitcoin over
non-esg friendly bitcoin
what they found in the market was that
not a single investor was willing to pay
more for esg bitcoin over non-esg
bitcoin
and so they said and i explicitly asked
him on the pocket this is a guy who
literally took his business uh him and
the rest of the executive team
and they started to do this esg
narrative and he said
it's all virtue signaling i specifically
asked him is this virtue signal he said
absolutely
and he said because if you believe this
is a better way
you should vote with your dollars you
should be willing to pay a premium
versus non-esg bitcoin what they found
was no one was willing to do that so
they flipped back and they said this is
all nonsense we are simply going to
mine bitcoin with the energy mix we
already have which we have found out
from the bitcoin mining council is over
50
of the energy used as renewable energy
based on the mining uh
uh businesses that are reporting into a
lot of publicly traded companies large
miners etc
and so if we get to that world what we
end up finding
is this whole use of esg is
nonsense but kathy wood maybe the
smartest person on the call yesterday
said you know what i'm still gonna use
that esg framework and apply it to
bitcoin it's gonna check every single
box and therefore
i can say with a straight face that
bitcoin is an esg asset if you're into
esg you should be into bitcoin which i
tend to agree with her
absolutely and if you look at uh you
know we can it's certainly virtually
signaling to some degree but at some
point you get held accountable for that
kind of stuff right you say hey look you
mentioned it this many times you said
you're gonna allocate this like where
are the results
uh so i think eventually like the
numbers have shown that we've seen some
kind of asset
and capital flow into that space
probably not as much as people expected
given kind of the use of the words and
stuff like that
but if you can tie it to bitcoin and the
people that want to uh invest in bitcoin
now have a mandate to go invest in esg
assets makes a lot of sense well so
here's the best part about the esg
stuff okay if we want to be esg
conscience then stop using dollars
right have you ever seen the meme where
they pull it up buy gold no and they're
like
uh they're like esg uh they're like
bitcoin and it's got the computers
running to secure the network
and then they're like the dollar and
it's literally they've got like a
warship
in the water with all of the planes uh
flying over top of it and they're like
uh hashtag security right like which one
is worse for the environment of course
the other one right
and so i think that it is uh to some
degree
people generally feel like uh we should
do the right things for the environment
i think there's nobody who's like we
should destroy the environment right
you're gonna be hard-pressed to find
somebody who explicitly thinks we should
destroy the environment i don't think
that anyone says hey we should do things
that
intentionally inflict pain on people
from a societal standpoint i don't think
you're gonna find a lot of people who do
that
governance hey we should be bad at
governance i don't think anyone does
that either but what i do think is when
you put together esg
and you use it you know as a marketing
term rather than an
actionable idea what you get is exactly
where we've landed which is there's a
bunch of virtue signaling and there's
not a lot of action to back it up
if the company said you know what we
actually are
going to pursue an esg initiative and
we are going to make a b c and d changes
here is exactly the impact on our
business here's the economic impact etc
i think people take it much more
seriously but what we find is literally
it is simply a marketing term now
and when you have esg as a marketing
term what it leads to
is either one of two worlds one people
just keep talking and not doing
or two you have people smart like kathy
wood who say you know what we're going
to
do
we're simply going to take esg framework
and we're going to fit our asset into it
and now we have appeased you
esg community even though we know you're
full of [ __ ] we now appease you and
therefore
if you are an esg proponent you must be
a bitcoin proponent because it checks
all the boxes
if you are not a bitcoin proponent but
still claim to be an esg proponent we're
calling
fraud on you right we're basically we're
calling your bluff you are absolutely
now just anti-bitcoin has nothing to do
with esg
and if you're going to be anti-bitcoin
that's okay but we've now exposed
that your excuse of esg narrative is
completely without water